oui
avoir m'entendez ouais on soir en
novembre 2015
peu de temps après les événements qui
ont frappé paris les attentats j'ai
ressenti le besoin de me recueillir
devant ces lieux que je connaissais bien
il faut que je vous dise que ma mère vit
au dessus du restaurant le p'ti cambodge
un lieu que nous fréquentons vraiment
souvent et j'avais envie quelques jours
après de me retrouver devant cette
terrasse qui avait été frappé lourdement
alors je suis descendu et là je me suis
retrouvé devant ce bout de trottoir
minuscule minuscule jamais je n'avais vu
une ville aussi vulnérable alors je me
suis tenu comme ça j'ai ressenti des
sentiments très varié très
contradictoires il y avait de la colère
il y avait de la rage il y avait du
chagrin
il y avait un sentiment d'impuissance
que vous avez sans doute éprouvé vous
aussi j'étais sans voix et j'étais sans
mots alors je suis remonté chez ma mère
j'ai pris un crayon et un petit carnet
et j'ai écrit ces quelques lignes sur
les trottoirs gris les bouquets de
fleurs fanées
comme ils sont mouillés sur les
trottoirs gris les bouquets de fleurs
fanées comme ils sont mouillés
j'avais écrit haïkus enfin un poème
d'inspiration japonaise d'origine
japonaise d'environ 17 syllabes en trois
lignes 5 7 5 syllabes ça n'était rien
c'était un souffle le sentiment fugace
qui passait mais d'avoir écrit cela ça
m'a aidé à cadrer mes émotions
ça m'a aidé à les exprimer et à en
garder une trace et je peux vous dire
que ce soir quand je vous en parle et
quand je relis ce haïkus j'ai la même
émotion qui revient
alors comment cela est-il possible
comment - pascal chaque journaliste
formé au celsa donc habitués à des
enquêtes nourrit longue des
documentations très construite
habitué à illustrer mes propos comment
moi qui ne suis jamais allé au japon qui
ne parle pas japonais
comment suis-je en train de devenir une
jean c'est à dire quelqu'un qui écrit
des c'est quand même fort de café
et bien tout est venu il ya une dizaine
d'années d'un dîner avec une amie on
discutait toutes les deux et elle me dit
je suis très fatigué en ce moment je
dors très très mal ah bon
ma curiosité s'éveille et là elle me dit
je passe mes nuits sur internet a
échangé des poèmes bref avec des poètes
québécois alors ça j'avais jamais
entendu ça c'était vraiment inouïe et
comme je suis journaliste
j'ai enquêté et là j'ai découvert un
monde un monde qui se passe à notre insu
sans doute qui est en train de se
diffuser tranquillement sans doute grâce
à internet on dit que les fondateurs de
twitter se sont inspirés du haïku
japonais pour créer leur réseau social
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce nano poèmes
17 syllabes je vous rappelle un souffle
il est né au xviie siècle au japon et il
continue à se diffuser en masse alors au
japon évidemment il faut savoir que les
quotidiens nationaux des grands
quotidiens nationaux reçoivent six à
sept mille haïkus de lecteurs par an
notamment quand il ya des catastrophes
comme fukushima où quand il ya des
moments politiques les lecteurs envoient
leurs haïkus qui sont sélectionnés mais
il n'y a pas qu'au japon en suède fondu
de haïkus au maroc
oujda est la ville principale du haïkus
au québec aux états unis
et en france où finalement sans que nous
le sachions vraiment dans les ateliers
d'écriture dans les écoles dans les
hôpitaux dans les maisons de retraite
peu à peu ce petit format
ce souffle d'ailleurs je voulais dit
deux fois quand je voulais dit il est
tellement court qu'il doit être dit deux
fois et en japonais
il doit être dit dans une expiration
c'est vous dire à quel point c'est léger
c'est vous dire à quel point c'est rien
donc je découvrais que ce haïkus se
diffuser tranquillement alors je me suis
posé une question pourquoi internet bien
sûr ils voyagent léger donc c'est facile
de s'échanger internationalement de
traverser les frontières grâce aux
nouvelles technologies mais pas
seulement
ce que j'ai découvert et ça ça
intéressera tous les communicants que
vous êtes
c'est que si ce petit format se diffuse
aussi bien c'est parce qu'ils diffusent
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est quoi
d'abord il est profondément démocratique
il est né au xviie siècle à une époque
où la poésie appartenait aux lettrés de
la cour et ou petit à petit des pauvres
des paysans des moines s'empare de la
poésie pour grandir socialement et
traverse le japon il s'échange comme ça
des poèmes il participe à des concours
ça donne lieu à des joutes et il se
développe
ils deviennent eux aussi des poètes donc
dans son adn il ya quand même quelque
chose de l'ordre d'une démocratie de
quelque chose qui s'ouvre mais pas
seulement
d'abord il ya cette briefe tu es qui
pour nous est vraiment une interrogation
nous qui croulons sous les blogs trop
long sous les commentaires sous les
dossiers nourrit le haïku avec sa
brièveté nous rappelle que la vie passe
en un souffle et à chaque fois que vous
écoutez un haïku ce que vous entendez
dans son silence c'est cette vie qui
passe et ça cela vient du bouddhisme zen
qui a nourri cette poésie c'est presque
moines qui traverse l japon en écrivant
des mini poèmes
il n'avait de cesse de rappeler
l'impermanence de la vie
donc à chaque fois qu un haïku passe
c'est un instant si vous ne deviez
retenir qu'une chose ce soir c'est cela
un hic où c'est un instant mais il n'ya
pas que ça haïku c'est aussi une
formidable célébration de la nature sans
cesse parce qu'on doit toujours dans ses
premiers poèmes évoqué un animal une
plante un végétal donc c'est pour ça
quand vous lisez des haïkus ce qui m'est
arrivé les premières fois j'avais
l'impression de d'avoir une fontaine de
jouvence qui m'arrivait j'entendais
parler d'érable de glycine de lucioles
de loutres qui sortait des rivières que
des mots que je n'avais pas entendu les
avais jamais entendu c'est le deuxième
effet du haïku il nous rappelle que nous
appartenait en cosmos avec tous ces
êtres vivants et que du coup nous avons
notre place comme celle outre comme ces
lucioles
la troisième chose enfin fait que haïkus
c'est l'anti bling bling dans cette
poésie on ne trouve que des bols en bois
des cabanes des chemins de terre des
bâtons des sandales délices de traverser
la rivière d'été sandales en main
délices de traverser la rivière d'été
sandales en main vous rendez compte ça a
été écrit au xviie siècle par un moine
et je suis sûr que parmi vous il y en a
plein qui ont vécu ça qui peuvent
s'identifier
pourquoi parce que c'est la vie simple
la vraie vie des vrais gens avec
l'essentiel
donc petit à petit c'est ce que je
raconte dans mon livre je me suis rendu
compte que le haïkus était une forme de
méditation active
ça me permettait d'être plus présente en
lire et en écrire me permettait d'être
plus présent de faire attention aux
petits détails aux instants qui passe et
de développer ce que les moines zen
appelle le shiori le shiori c'est la
sympathie pour toute chose qui vient à
vous les êtres vivants et le monde
alors aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
d'altruisme de compassion d'emploi des
grands mots en réalité la sympathie pour
les choses changent votre vie donc
réalisant ça je me suis je peux dire
transformer et je revendique cette
pratique poétique comme une méditation
active accessible à tout le monde
c'est pour ça qu'on la prend dans les
écoles aussi alors vous allez me dire
que par rapport à notre poésie fleury
métaphorique
finalement on ne peut pas exprimer grand
chose en 17 syllabes et bien détrompez
vous par exemple il ya aujourd'hui des
consultants financiers qui écrivent des
haïkus de bureau igor cayzelle peyron
c'est son nom il a écrit celui ci par
exemple dans l'open space le ficus et
moi
dans l'open space le ficus et moi on a
tous vécu ça on est dans une réunion
n'en peut plus ans tourne au regard
d'une plante on dit la bienheureuse
je peux aussi vous raconter une histoire
d'amour en 3 x 17 x 3 56 labs maximum
les débuts de l'amour d'abord avec un
poète qui s'appelle la bâche likoud zai
douceur de printemps au fond du lit ta
culotte douceur de printemps au fond du
lit
ta culotte et puis le couple s'installa
envie de vivre le quotidien
et là c'est un poète qui s'appelle
bicocchi nous dit ça tu as encore tiède
sur la trace de ses lèvres posées mes
lèvres traces encore tu as encore tiède
lèvres voilà le couple vit cette
merveilleuse période de compagnonnage et
puis et puis un poète qui s'appelle mg
craque pour nous donne sa version finale
le temps passe elle décide de plus en
plus
plus vous voyez je vous ai raconté une
histoire d'amour en même pas 50 syllabes
donc c'est possible enfin s'il est aussi
puissant dans sa manière de transcender
les frontières de toucher des esprits
qui ne connaissent rien au japon rien à
cette culture c'est aussi parce qu'il
est vraiment partageur le haïku n'est
jamais fini
ce n'est pas une ces petites frontières
cc 17 syllabes qui sont des frontières
minuscule ne sont pas fermées c'est vous
qu'il est fini c'est d'ailleurs un peu
raide a dit le haïk ouïe comme un cercle
ouvert par le poète est fermée par le
lecteur parce que c'est vous par votre
interprétation qui allait finir par
exemple haïkus contemporain écrit
pendant les présidentielles par un poète
qui s'appelle ben couderc il écrit celui
ci visite chez mon père le tee shirt
tout pourri de poutous visite chez mon
père
le t-shirt ou pourris de toutous qu'est
ce que vous entendez qui s'est engueulé
avec son père à cause du tee shirt de
poutous ou bien que le t-shirt de
poutous que portait son père l'a mis en
colère bien que lui même porté le même
t-shirt que poutou c'est vous qui allez
terminer ce prime c'est vous qui êtes
renvoyé à votre vie à votre histoire
pour le terminer
d'ailleurs j'ai un petit cadeau pour
vous grâce à toute l'équipe magnifique
du celsa qui m'a aidé à le mettre en
place ce soir vous allez repartir avec
un hic ou le vôtre celui qui vous est
tombé par hasard ce soir alors vous
allez le ramener chez vous allez lire
vous allez vous demander ce qu'il veut
bien raconter vous allez vous dire
qu'est ce que ça m'évoque sur ma vie sur
mes relations
quelle est cette sagesse ancienne comme
ça qui arrive grâce à cet événement
il est sous votre siège pouvait regarder
l'équipe du celsa vous a collé si je
puis dire coup sous le siège
c'est vrai vous allez repartir avec
cette petite chose à ce souffle
je vous souhaite de le regarder de le
mentionner dans votre tête de le méditer
j'espère qu'avec hui vous franchirez vos
propres frontières merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]